це та адміністрація яка переслідувала
Генерала марченка Генерала павловського
Сашка погребиського Андрія Антоненка
Юлію Кузьменко мене і Марусю звіробій це
та судова адміністрація яка понад 20
годин вчора тримала Романа червінського
без їжі без води без адвокатів під час
судового засідання без можливості
доступу до лікарів це та судова
адміністрація яка сьогодні спричинила те
що в Романа червінського віднялися руки
і ноги і йому навіть не можуть
забезпечити нормального медичного
догляду та Совість треба мати таким
судовим адміністраціям в час війни
додавати 422 млн грн колеги я вас дуже
прошу включіть мізки і передайте ці 422
млн на потреби збройних сил України і
Перестаньте переслідувати наших
захисників